[Music]  if et social study was the stars are  posting online the way in the rock  Johnson reflects on this priceless  moment where he went undercover with  Jimmy Fallon and brought a fan to tears  saying he'll never forget the special  day that moments like these are the best  parts of faith then there's Mandy  Moore's celebrating her 33rd birthday at  Disneyland with her squad and boyfriend  Taylor goldsmith that this is a star and  her beau were spotted wearing nearly  identical outfits matching shirts  jackets and trendy Sony's it's really  not hard to just love him meanwhile pink  shares a cute pic laughing with her  husband Carey Hart that read this dude  is hot moving on the original America's  Next Top Model judges Nigel Barker Miss  J Alexander and Jay Manuel adorably  reunite quote this trio back together  cat walking on New York City streets can  only  one thing and chris hemsworth shows off  his impressive surfing skills in  australia  [Music]